on land
on the Metro
torrential rains wreaking havoc across
Spain
as motorists-based flooded roads
Emergency Services tended to more than 1
200 incidents in the Madrid region alone
where sudden heavy rain caused chaos
after a summer of record temperatures
[Applause]
in Toledo the capital of the Castilla
mancha region the city's Industrial Area
was inundated trains were canceled
leaving residents and tourists alike
stranded
was really crazy we kept going outside
and we were looking at the clouds we're
like okay are we gonna be safe what's
gonna happen but it just kept raining
and but even catching a bus proved
difficult as garages were heavily
flooded leaving Vehicles stuck amid the
mud
in the Catalan town of alcanar the
downpour turned this Rural Road into a
river
confining residents to their homes
leaving behind a trail of damage in its
wake
we organized amongst ourselves to make
ropes with towels and bed sheets and use
them to pull two young men who were
grabbing onto the columns we've pulled
them to the top floor and saved them it
was terrifying very very scary with
small children women nobody showed up we
were left alone to save ourselves
while the ferocity of the Reigns has
begun to subside the damage they caused
remains evident and the clear-up
significant
Spain's national weather service has
lowered the alert level from red to
Yellow but it is far from normal for
many to resume their usual activities in
the worst affected areas
Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera